nostalgia critic reviewing commercials
like you give a shit
oh what's the Green Goblin up to now
oh no he's forcing spider-man to play
his own Atari game actually that is kind
of watch yourself oh no this is an
enjoyably goofy commercial but what
really sells it is the guy playing the
gap fighting in a barren time part of AA
I think his dentist put meth in his
laughing gas if I don't get you one head
nothing well here Li huh I love this guy
he can't believe the frame without going
nuts stop presenting show some dignity
when you're in that costume
clearly you're running out of blow
what's he even saying here he's so
excited I can't make it out y'all
running out what you're running out of
low okay I've watched this over a
hundred times I've studied it I've
analyzed every possibility I still don't
know what the hell he said y'all running
out here are my closest guesses y'all
running you're running you're running
you're running out
we laugh at this but honestly it's not
too far off from what some of the movies
have if Goblin and spider-man can relax
on a roof in those ridiculous outfits
playing Atari game isn't too far off I
could crush you like a bug right now but
let's play video games instead seriously
you told her your hunch yeah it was a
good pick-up line for some reason I've
got to be less awkward than how I cut a
Thanksgiving turkey or crawl on the
floor to a chair with a Spencer's mask
on it yeah let's hope nothing as
ridiculous is in our near future outside
of a song-and-dance number how couldn't
can I say but web slinging fun never
looks so pixelated
it's more action that even Spiderman can
handle whoa fighter man a video game
from Parker Brothers the ones to beat
here comes better extract whoa stand
back the world's most exciting toys are
here this is the Federal Express Air
Cargo playset yeah I remember how
jealous I was of the kids that had
Federal Express playsets here I was
watching the side of my painted house
dry I have no idea there's something
even more boring the door is opened and
a real conveyor system inside the plane
moves the containers into the cargo bay
hey slow down something so much
excitement we can take now Federal
Express takes off again with cargo for
Phoenix I have enough intensity with my
pet rock thank you very much
they're put in containers loaded on
trailers and taken to the plane ah did
that really deserve a WoW I could barely
muster in a the van delivers packages to
the airport I prepared for a lifetime of
disappointment New York Miami his
commercials pretty much as boring as it
sounds come on guys you had the micro
machine man working for you could you
utilize him somehow this is so boring my
skin is actually turning into cardboard
the Federal Express air cargo playset
comes with everything you see here from
playschool FedEx putting return to
sender on your kids imagination
think we'll beat that time sure we will
after this complete breakfast including
my frosted flakes ah Tony the Tiger you
represent everything youthful and strong
with the voice of an 80 year old let's
see if you're any good watch the plates
good we're alright though Tony's of
course still around there was a very
distinct formula that was used in the
80s and 90s ads you see it always starts
with Tony befriending some random kid
and some random sport who's always being
made fun of like boys you can't want to
take a horsey ride you two up for a
little game hey you see the kid eels
over there
time to tie our sweaters around our
chests and throw Cadillacs at puppies
hope your sir is good you guys never
knew kid we don't wanna you're stuck
with him what's wrong with these dipshit
you're making fun of a kid that has a
killer predator on his side this is not
gonna end well what the out good you are
what are you gonna do SiC your giant
animated tiger on me but of course it's
the great taste of frosted flakes that
brings out their inner tiger and
transforms them into a sports star be
that it very good good
you're gonna tigers
you see some false advertising in that
some me protein bars vegetables these
are things that can make you a better
athlete
sugar-frosted newspaper cannot nobody
says you know what make people who eat
Wheaties even stronger candy flavoring
there's even chocolate covered versions
with marshmallows how is any of this
supposed to make you a sports star if
they really want to be honest with the
ads they'd be like hey loser sanic your
parents died in a car crash I'll never
be as cool as those guys that's what you
think what you need is a helping of my
uh feelings it brings out the toughness
in you see figured good puffy flakes
good with it sugar wait what
oh yeah there's no weed in this we just
scrape off the top of sugar cubes and
dive in brown that sounds incredibly
unhealthy my girl show that unit
so what you can do I'm sluggish and slow
you just need more talking
give them guest tiger you make some
weird Goering sounds because you know
what's cool Friday I feel dizzy and weak
that's just the diabetes set again what
you need is some insulin keep them on
their toes Tiger you started your
breakfast right with what most people
call dessert when you have a taste of
Tuffy's toffee flakes it brings out the
top we're mostly miss advertised well
it's still fun and Tony such a great
mascot it's hard not to get sucked into
all the sports testing propaganda whoa
these kids gathered round for Johnny
he's gonna play silent nobody sighing
hey hey stand back son of a bitch thinks
he can take on Simon Wow girl I think
that jacket just put you through early
puberty I will smell Johnny's jacket all
through the night smells like
SpaghettiOs and victory hmm I want to
blow away this easily impressed group of
fourth-graders Simon is the challenge
you've been waiting for and if you get
very good at some great rewards with you
yes if you take on the challenge of
pushing beeping buttons you get the
great reward of them beeping without you
pushing up the tips coordination of hand
and mind just pretty I love how politely
he thanks the Machine before he soaks up
the victory
ah I want to thank you for a challenging
game it really did well to enhance my
reflexes ah look at these kids
it's just simon guys i mean what do you
think this is crossfire you may be cool
simon but you're not crossfire being
played by dante basco dressed as
firebender Zucco cool check out the
lucky gives when the girl puts the
jacket on him he's just like girl you my
bitch now
Simon Says I own your ass it ain't
crossfire but as game commercials go
it's a close second Simon is waiting for
you from Milton Bradley you my bitch now
one kids meal right away we all know
McDonald's has Rama Macdonald before a
while Burger King had the Burger King
kids club it lasted for a good chunk of
time until they realized the 90s wanted
to die and this was the last remaining
threaded I mean look at them they're
drenched in the 90s it even has all the
90s token characters the token geeky kid
the token Hispanic kid the token black
kid the token wheelchair kid and ooh -
token girls the nineties are ready truth
be told it was kinda neat to have such a
wide variety but they never really had
any characteristics like the McDonald's
commercials
Ronald was confidently goofy grimace was
a doofus Hamburglar was a troublemaker
what are these kids at story um they
kidnap kids through black magic and
don't forget to clean your room
this'll take you away from your ethical
obligations they take pictures of boys
bathing okay you and this girl neither
talking to turn away people they don't
like belong to the Burger King he does
no no your turning away dinosaurs what's
wrong with you your coolness would have
gone up a million percent if you had a
t-rex as a member not for crew that's
trying to be so open and accepting you
sure say no do a lot of people not
scream bagpipe players they can go to
hell no wonder your characters never
sold that great hey guys want to go to
the toy store no Burger King may toys
boring I don't know they'll ever get a
reaction from us again well look too
soon
a valiant attempt but they don't even
mention their names in the commercials
oh we're gonna see em Eze is the black
kid the Hispanic kid and Cyclops what do
they call you wheels actually yes
awkward Barca King gets close it's
justified and just for you this is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard
bright ideas
always a classic jingle for a classic
product but while we all remember how to
dunk it eat an Oreo cookie what is up
with these kids reaction to them I swear
you could freeze any of these and it
looks like the Oreos are opening up the
Dark Dimension from Doctor Strange
look even transform this kid into a
young Bill Cosby which is probably gonna
be very bad in the future you got the
Wiggles all over the blade that takes on
a whole new meaning don't look directly
into this boy's eyes it'll send you
directly to help
good day sir it wasn't humanly possible
well here it is folks
the first ever Gameboy commercial and
I'm not gonna lie they may have
overhyped it now you can have all the
power and excitement of Nintendo right
in the palm of your hand really all the
power and excitement of Nintendo huh is
that why in this 30-second commercial
there is only one second of gameplay in
it I'm not even kidding this is the only
clip of game footage they show but look
giant robots on Doctor Who sets like it
can't even that's a little awkward I'm
sorry but seeing a giant machine come
out and hold a calculator like a texting
gourd doesn't look especially
intimidating the loser has to watch the
Keanu Reeves version and it's games are
interchangeable Plus vegan boy comes
with the outrageous new game Tetris
outrageous Tetris ah there's many words
to describe Tetris but outrageous isn't
usually one of them so outrageous that
only one second of it can be shown to
show the rest of it would blow your mind
too much
okay if you want to do an ad truthfully
you do it like this
now you can have all the power and
excitement of Nintendo right in the palm
of your hands and by all we mean
literally one color roughly four bits
and a variety of maybe five side effects
really crappy robots from the 60s looked
you could give the game gear which in
hindsight was a million times better but
because ours was a tiny bit smaller it
bombed
enjoy what your mom will be playing on
her phone in 20 years
wait does my existence rely on this I
totally didn't shut aim boy only from
Nintendo a phone that even if it is
overhyped now you're playing with power
or durable power every morning at this
time the dad puts one of those great
they go on for the coaster yep who can
forget leggo my eggo the catchphrase
nobody said because nobody would ever
fight for one
they go my eggo leggo my eggo but in the
commercials everybody wanted one it
would go to crazy lengths to get it even
though they were clearly many left
behind I feel like these are some
extreme lengths to go to to get one of
them let they come in like pegs of 812
you can come on guys time is ride for me
and go something probably the most
extreme is a kid that created an
invisibility suit with science like away
I go you're sinning against time in
nature for an eggo waffle the wound is
not ready for such technology or
deliciousness it's cute and all but
these ideas were done today I think they
might have gone a different direction
my dad always tries to get my egg waffle
in the morning before I do
but with my black arts magic the
advantage is mine I do it cool I'm just
a mom who you did it kiss I saw the Sun
now you see like gosh don't go and
that's how it's done
oh no you don't 11 this egg waffle is
mine
Eagle waffles is part of a complete
breakfast leggo Mike I'll shut up weird
but harmless enough
aigo knows how to focus on stranger
things and then that's weird ones like
this they either show you an advertising
but black I never got them tell me what
you think
we're right so random shopping makes me
hungry love a lot bear cake yes many of
you know that Care Bears were a thing
for a while and that included toys I'm
not even sure I always got them like one
was for dress-up did girls like to dress
up bears was that a thing we're nudists
and proud but strangely enough the most
frightening thing is when they would
speak I know that doesn't sound like
anything but just listen to when they
talk Sammy wants to you Christ you
should take voice lessons from the girl
in the ring they also make cheap
novelties when you can't afford actual
presence yeah it'll help you cheer from
the sidelines no seriously what you give
me my goddamn leg is broken as well as
ruining birthdays okay dear thank you
into yeah no wonder he has no friends at
this party is excited to get a Care Bear
stay there I'm gonna beat you up after
this review come to tender heart beer
how much don't crowd give us no that was
not a good frame to freeze on this is it
to say even the toddler's figure out
quickly they're being gypped
hey as long as they don't talk and see
yourself lucky kid oh I guess I got the
job done but did they have to be so
cutely freaky and share your special
feelings today
when that clock strikes this character
was kind of cool
he was called Mac tonight also known as
moon sole purpose was to let you know
that McDonald's is open later and dare
we say a classy place to hang out at
night the answer is no you may not dare
to say look cool and the character was
pretty neat but I'm sorry this would
never convince anyone McDonald's is an
upscale place to be your just ain't
gonna happen
mmm when these McNuggets are especially
Chiklis today
oh hello Andre hello Alexander I was
busy having a griddle of the Nik variety
oh how frightfully witty why isn't that
Julius from Walmart never mind me I'm
just seeing if they still have the
McLobster
oh is that a thing yes yes that is I
guess it doesn't help that this moon guy
is also a little creepy just watch what
happens when you switch out the music
from this actual ad they used to play
I will stab your heart with a chair only
I am Bruce Campbell can do that still a
cool character even if he is a bit
nightmare-inducing is Mac no don't make
it back tonight may be absolutely
remarkable my interactive Pooh Oh
where's he yours yeah Oh review phone do
you
Jordan arey new COO why are we talking
about extraordinary new Pooh are we
having lunch with Grandpa again who
interacts with your child and computers
are always that sounds very unsanitary
download and take Foods bunny anywhere
take Pooh fun anywhere I'd imagine get
arrested for something like that hello
yeah no I'm Way too childish to talk
about a children's commercial but let's
just say this isn't my number one
commercial but it's definitely my number
two incredible new my interactive poop
okay wow this goes back a PSA from when
the Adam West Batman show was still on
let's see what 60s Batman had to throw
at us
quick Batgirl untie us before it's too
late it's already too late I've worked
for you a long time and I'm paid less
than Robin she's holy disk same job same
employer means equal pay for men and
women no time for jokes that girl
it's no joke it's the Federal Equal Pay
law oh yeah
can we talk about this later will
Batgirl save the dynamic duo will she
got equal pay
contact the wage and hour division
Department of Lake okay
where do I start with this first of all
Adam West is really phoning it in
isn't he his life is on the line yet it
sounds like he's teaching a geometry
class quickback girl untie us before
it's too late and please tell me the
property for ex second Batman's kind of
an asshole equal pay for men and women
no time for jokes Batgirl
Wow what a douche I mean come on your
vagina alone docks you like 20% even
Robins like come on you crazy Dame we
gave you the boat what else do you want
third superheroes get paid when did this
start our superheroes getting regular
wages do they have a union plus I don't
know what the paychecks are but the idea
of anyone getting paid less than Robin
is frigging hilarious fourth she's just
gonna let Batman die kids at home must
be pissing themselves she's about to
kill their favorite hero and a young boy
that girl's gonna become everyone's most
hated characters as The Killing Joke
fifth even with the threat of killing
Batman women still are given equal pay
this was made back in the 60s and it's
still unequal we'd rather see one of our
favorite superheroes dive and give a few
more bucks to these weird timid
creatures dude if that's not gonna do
anything I don't know what will sex
while it is well-intentioned is this
really the best time for Batgirl to
bring this up couldn't I like sit down
and discuss a back and forth or protest
or I don't know call your Congressman
like you just said
I mean how awkward must things be
between Batman and Batgirl after this
situation
defuse the bomb you know this reminds me
of the time when I was in a similar
situation yes I'll remember yeah you
were gonna let me explode if you didn't
get equal pay no you're talking about
you know world hunger is still a big
issue no no no I'm serious I'm actually
thinking maybe we should put your life
on the line until we get world hunger
solved you know you stay there and blow
up I don't get my powerpoint
presentation
Oh
okay I'm still here though a
well-meaning message done in a
hilariously ridiculous way what else can
you say but holy acts of Congress I'm
halfway to our division Department of
Labor
here's another PSA from Canada oh no no
no no no I before by your psh before
Canada you always try to make them look
so friendly and nice but then there's
rape whistles and face burnings and
putting things in your mouth
well I'm ready for you this time Canada
do your worst it's nighttime in a
kitchen just like yours all is quiet or
is it better that what I said was that
the North American house hippo is found
throughout Canada in the eastern United
States that house hippos are very timid
creatures and a rarely seen but they
will defend their territory of provoked
they come out at night to search for
food water and materials for their nests
what is it any children or something the
favorite foods of the house hippo are
chips
raisins and the crumbs from peanut
butter on toast point for your cuteness
cattle where you go with us they build
their nests in bedroom closets using
lost mittens dryer lint and get some
string and then they flamethrower your
family don't smoke now suppose sleep
about 16 hours a day that look really
real but you knew it couldn't be true
didn't you that's why it's good to think
about what you're watching on TV and ask
questions kind of like you just did the
message from concerned children's
advertisers well that was nice downright
adorable so let me get this straight
Canada you start off your dark
disturbing PSAs as cute and innocent and
start off your cute and innocent PSAs as
dark and disturbing what are you Canada
you're like a riddle inside an enigma
inside up please and thank you
okay cool the house hippo don't believe
everything you see
fair enough a cute harmless even
educational PSA it's good for you Canada
I will not have nightmares tonight okay
we could Canada we good thank you for
that enlightening very pleasant PSA no
on to the next one
okay so here's one from Britain called
electricity football oh cool I always
wonder what their version of electric
football was like no oh it's that kind
of football that's fun I'm still curious
to see how kids play that I know Mike
Tyson everyone you walk it on touch
anything not seeing any quadrant boards
was this a Parker Brothers game oh Jesus
also we haven't
they say stay out don't take a chance
with electricity
I'm afraid of branch and now your new
Canada your new Canada stay up Oh trust
me I will you electric you kids like bug
zappers you said yes AG Breton you can
keep your terry gilliam cuz your sec Oh
finally a star purse commercial ok
something a little less freaky you tried
these new berries and cream starburst
pardon me what kind of star busters you
just say berries berries
everything what else cream oh ok
commercial I'll bite where are you going
with this berries and cream berries and
cream I'm a little louder those berries
and cream berries give up just give up
give up on everything what are we doing
is this really what we're paying people
to give us now we're denying good
writers such wonderful paycheck so that
piece of shit writers can give us this
this was a gift that only the rare
exceptional talent could give us and we
said yes let's make this a hit let's
reward the asshole who came up with this
on his lunch break stoned off his ass
when he went in to pitch that's
commercial and they said Larry you're
stoned off your ass and Larry said yes I
am and they said well 11 million people
are stoned off their asses too cuz 11
million people watched it on YouTube and
not only that they shared it and came
back for more they said I'm not talented
enough to come up with something so
ingenious and you got more there are
remixes of this commercial there's other
variations of this commercial from
different angles completely different
mind you look
diversion ray says this those new
berries and cream star bus that
completely changes the dynamic of
everything it was trying to accomplish
is this what takes help it says what if
I want to sell those black cows would I
be like you black tote bag couch I
pooped a black out and I would sell like
a badge a pike with black couches stocks
just don't through the roof if I play
that ad I say no to you berries and
cream
I say no I've taken a lot of stupidity
over the years but this lunacy madness
take I will not this commercial is awful
it's just stupid and awful
I'm sick of insanity being rewarded I'm
sick of laziness being counted as clever
I want something to make sense there's
good reason for my glistening skin and
how my pores are so clean and clear I
eat little baby's ice cream it keeps me
young
it keeps me light on my feet I spring
from activity to activity when you eat
little baby's ice cream you'll wink and
nod with great enthusiasm ice cream is a
feeling okay okay yeah
I apologized that version of me has
expired
he simply had nothing more to give he
tried he tried very very hard to look
inside himself to find something
anything that he could offer but in the
end you just took too much from him
world it just took too much from him he
will be missed a moment of silence if
you
me on the other hand oh wow this is the
freakiest thing I have ever seen this is
for something called little baby's ice
cream it would scare the piss out of any
little babies watching it it's so
terrifying but I even convinced it's
made for little babies I think it's made
out of little babies don't believe me
watch it again and just take out the ice
cream part tell me if it makes a little
too much sense I eat little babies it
keeps me young
it keeps me light on my feet when you
eat little babies
you'll wink and nod this is a special
time little babies is a feeling little
baby's ice cream is people well if
there's anything I've learned from this
commercial special it's that fear sells
everything so without further ado I have
a black couch to sell and I know the
best way to do it blackout - uh blackout
- creepy food people with pointy heads
and chins and he'll kill you in your
sleep by the couch Oreo kids that eat
your soul with o2
oh shit Oh black cheese I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and pleasant dreams
okay don't get that scared just making a
real fast announcement here on December
4th that's a Sunday at 11 a.m. at the
Barnes & Noble in Naperville Illinois my
brother and I are doing a short little
panel just about an hour long talking
about Christmas specials the best and
worst Christmas specials there are and
we're going to invite you guys to bring
up some of your favorites and some of
your worst and afterwards we're going to
have a little meat and greed you know
we'll sign autographs and DVDs and
prints and stuff like that anything you
bring to sign as well and we did this
one year before and it went over
wonderful and we're just doing it again
because we love Christmas it's coming up
and we're so excited so again that's
Naperville Illinois the Barnes & Noble
their December 4th at 11 a.m. we would
love to see you guys hopefully we will
see you there come on over let's talk
Christmas specials take care
you
you're running out of low
me again once again doing the charity
shout-out this week we are doing the
foundation for AIDS research founded in
1985 the foundation for AIDS research is
dedicated to ending the global AIDS
epidemic through innovative research
with the freedom and flexibility to
respond quickly to emerging areas of
scientific promise they play a major
role in accelerating the pace of HIV and
AIDS research and achieving real
breakthroughs they're funded research
has increased our understanding of HIV
and has helped lay the groundwork for
major advances in the study and
treatment of it since 1985 they have
invested nearly 340 million dollars in
its mission and has awarded grants to
more than 2,000 research teams worldwide
help them win this fight against HIV and
AIDS by going to their site watching
their inspiring videos and donating
today there can be a cure if we all do
our best to make it happen take a look
and please donate
you